derrière des boucliers de fortune des
militants antiracistes barricades et
font face à un écran de gaz lacrymogènes
un cordon d'hommes en uniformes
paramilitaires et un arsenal
impressionnant
des scènes qui semble se répéter
inlassablement chaque nuit et pour
lesquels le ministre américain de la
justice williams bar a été entendue
devant la commission judiciaire de la
chambre des représentants au capitole
les élus démocrates reprochent au
ministre de la justice d'avoir servi les
intérêts de donald trump en envoyant la
garde nationale des états unis
en réponse aux émeutes nous craignons
que ce problème ne produisent des
métastases dans le pays et donc nous
pensons que dans un lieu comme tout le
monde où nous n'avons pas le soutien de
l'état et des autorités locales
nous devons prendre le position et
défendre ce bâtiment fédéral qui n'ont
pas atteindre un stade où nous acceptons
ce type d'attaqués violentes sur les
tribunaux fédéraux
l'administration de donald trump d'y
avoir entamé des pourparlers avec le
bureau du gouverneur de l'orégon et la
présence d'agents fédéraux envoyées pour
réprimer les manifestations à portland
pourrait être réduite si l'état augmente
la présence de la police locale jugés
inefficaces par le président américain
oui nous avons fait un excellent travail
assure b portland est notre tribunal
qu'il voulait brûler ce sont les
anarchistes rayon de moins que du phanar
schiste des agitateurs et nous l'avons
protéger avec beaucoup de force
si on n'y était pas allé je vous le dis
il n'y aurait pas du tribunal il y
aurait un bâtiment à un milliard de
dollars brûlé aucun accord n'a été
conclu pour le moment les maire
démocrate de civils des états unis dont
portland chicago et washington ont
demandé au congrès est l'arrêt définitif
d'envoi d'agents fédéraux affirmant que
leur présence est à l'origine des
tensions de leur ville